(audience applauds)
- Can I sit on your couch?
- Yes.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] You look so great.
Oh, my gosh.
- Mama said, mama said,
"Show up with hostess gifts".
(Kelly laughs)
I don't know about all y'all,
but I was raised to show
up with a hostess gift.
- [Kelly] This is beautiful.
- So, this is... I have a
few for you, by the way.
- Oh my gosh, I literally have one.
So, the only other person to gift me this,
Gwen Stefani gave me one
for Christmas, one year
and I still...
- Oh, oh.
- No, so what I'm saying...
(audience laughs)
No, what I'm saying is I think
it's such a beautiful gift.
So, I'm going to hang it on my door.
- [Jamie] Well, of course, so.
- Yeah.
- As you know...
- Because that was in Montana,
I don't have one for here.
- Well, I'm born and raised
in the City of Angels.
I'm a California girl.
(audience applauds)
- I like it.
- You can clap for a California
girl, anytime you want.
(Kelly laughs)
So, we've never met, I was
on your show virtually.
- [Kelly] Virtually, yes.
- I started a little, company
called, My Hand in Yours,
which gives comfort items
and celebration items
to people in times of
crisis and celebration,
with 100% going to Children's
Hospital of Central
and I mean 100%.
(audience applauds)
But wait, wait, wait.
I'm saying it's the only store of its kind
where 100% of what you spend
is sent to the hospital, literally.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- This is, with Creekside
Farms, our new, holiday wreath.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- Which will be offered
on the site and wait...
- [Kelly] Which will
be on my door, tonight.
- Wait, wait.
- I love that you bring presents.
- Well again, Mama said,
"Show up with a hostess gift".
- Well, you were kind.
- I invented... I took My Hand in Yours
and I expanded it to My Paw in Yours,
because all of us have and
we now have a dog leash,
of My Paw in Yours.
- Yeah.
- And then last but not least
and the most important is...
This is the sculpture, of
a mom's hand with a child.
You're a mom and a fierce mama,
you are a fierce mama bear.
And this is the third of the sculptures.
All of those are available.
And just one more thing,
we also have a new baby
blanket on the site
for My Hand in Yours.
So, all of those are available.
- That's so cool.
- On my site, but these are gifts to you,
because you're awesome.
(audience applauds)
- Well, hey, thank you so much.
And you know, it is really, important
to point that out, that
100% of the proceeds go,
because that's not often,
that's not the case.
- But it's not even the
proceeds, 100% of the sales.
- Sorry, it's 100% of everything.
That's amazing.
- Because that, you know what?
I've been so blessed in my life,
my husband and I decided
to underwrite the company,
which means we pay for everything
and then anything you buy,
I just send every penny,
directly to the hospital.
And it's... Just so you know,
it's been one of the
greatest thrills of my life,
in a year, one year.
Last August 4th, we raised $350,000
for Children's Hospital Central.
(audience applauds)
- I love it, the reason
why I brought it up
is I thought it was an
amazing gift to give someone.
I've never given, I feel
like I'm a good, gift-giver
and I've never thought of that.
And speaking of animals,
I have to ask about a photo you posted.
So, what's happening here?
- [Jamie] Oh.
(Jamie laughs)
- [Kelly] What's happening?
- [Jamie] So...
(Jamie laughs)
- [Kelly] First of all...
- [Jamie] But the context is crazy.
So, I had just come back
from Venice Film Festival,
where at the ripe, old age of 62,
(audience applauds)
I was presented with a
Lifetime achievement award,
called the Golden Lion.
It's a prestigious award,
from an obviously,
beautiful, film festival.
And I had just come back, the day before,
with my Golden Lion and I go to the market
and there's a golden tiger,
like in line ahead of me.
And I thought, "What's happening here?"
So I took a picture of him,
this poor guy he's now on television.
Don't hate me.
(audience laughs)
I am so, sorry.
- I love it, I love it, I
think it's really, funny.
- I didn't know you'd
be on Kelly Clarkson.
It's not my fault.
- He's face is hidden.
- She did it.
- [Kelly] He's face is hidden.
Hey, when you come out like that,
you want your picture taken.
You also have a podcast because
you have like so many jobs.
- I have so much.
- You have so many things.
(Kelly laughs)
- So wait, it's called "Good Friend".
So, who's been a friend to get you through
like, really, tough times.
- Well, you know, COVID
was pretty tough and...
- I thought you were going
to say it was a friend.
(Kelly laughs)
- No, no.
You know, COVID was the reason
why I invented this podcast
called, "Good Friend"
because I realized it was
through these friendships
that I have, like we all did,
that's how we got through it.
We got through it, communicating, deeply
with the people that we loved.
And you know, I couldn't name
anybody on national television
because then I would be
sliding everybody else.
But I do find that my
friendships are the thing
that gets me through
the very, hardest times
and there are hard times, a lot of tears.
And then of course, the wonderful times.
And so, I just decided, you know,
I'd never hosted anything and I thought...
- Me neither.
- Yeah, far out.
And guess what? You're really, good at it.
- [Kelly] We're doing all
right, we're doing all right.
- You're doing just fine
there, Kelly Clarkson.
- I love that though,
that you have those...
I feel like, speaking of good friends,
I feel like the older I
get, and it was said to me,
when I was like, 19
getting in the industry,
it was like, be careful who
you surround yourself with.
And like... And you're really, only
are going to have so many friends,
like at the end of the day,
that are really like, get you.
And I thought, "How sad",
this individual telling me this,
because I had so many friends.
When in reality, I didn't
have that many friends.
I had like acquaintances,
but those good friends
that are there for you,
in the bad and good, that's amazing.
- Well, and Maria
Shriver referred to them,
which I had never heard before,
she referred to them on the
show as "flat tire friends".
- [Kelly] Oh.
- She said, "Who are
your flat tire friends?"
Who are those people you can call
when you're on the 405,
heading south, at rush hour
and you get a flat tire?
- Exactly.
- And AAA says, it'll be five hours.
Who do you call? And that level of trust,
show up, someone who will suit up
and show up for you, which is crucial.
- And then also, call you out, yeah.
- Well, I won't ever call
you out, Kelly Clarkson.
- What?
- We're new friends, we're just getting
to know each other.
- You have to call people out.
That's how you get in,
you have to call them out.
I don't like people who don't call me out.
- Okay, by the way, there's the book
that you could write today.
- I'm just saying there's
enough turds running around
that people don't call out.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
We need to start calling
each other out more.
- I agree with you.
(audience applauds)
- I think that's real friendship.